ETSY PITCHMEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: A LOT OF STUFF ON ETSY
FALLS INTO ONE OF TWO
CATEGORIES.
ADORABLE FELT TRINKETS TAHT
LOOK LIKE THEY WERE FARTED INTO
A TEACUP BY TEAGAN AND SARA,
OR INSANE MYSTERY BOBBLES
THAT LOOK LIKE THEY WERE LEFT
BEHIND BY A REDNECK MURDERER.
COMEDIANS WE'RE GOING TO SHOW
YOU THINGS THAT ARE EITHER
PRECIOUS, TERRIFYING OR BOTH.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO COME UP
THE DON DRAPER STYLE PITCH NEED
THE PITCH TO SELL IT
FIRST ONE, JAR OF HUMAN TOE
NAILS.
REALLY MORE OF A VIAL, I WOULD
SAY.
PAUL.
>> ARE THEY FROM SEVERAL PEOPLE
OR JUST ONE WEIRD PERSON WITH A
LOT OF CARROTIN.
YOU WILL FIND OUT WHEN YOU GROW
YOUR OWN CLONE ARMY.
POINTS. EXCELLENT. MARY LYNN.
>> STAYS CRUNCHY IN MILK AND IS
ONE OF THE FOUR FOOT GROUPS.
>> Chris: POINTS MARY LYNN. ONE
OF THE FOUR.
>> ONE.
Chris: WHAT ARE THE OTHER
THREE FOOT GROUPS.
>> YOU KNOW CORNS, BUNIONS --
Chris: I DIDN'T KNOW CORNS
HAD THEIR OWN -- OKAY. SCOTT DO
YOU --
>> IF YOU ACT NOW I WILL THROW
IN THE TOES.
>> Chris: EXCELLENT. POINTS.
WELL DONE.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
BABIES IN A CAN.
WHICH IS SOLD OUT BY THE WAY.
MARY LYNN.
>> DON'T HAVE TIME TO MAKE
BABIES FROM SCRATCH.
COMES WITH HONEY MUSTARD, BLUE
CHEESE AND RANCH.
>> Chris: POINTS. SCOTT.
>> SAVE THESE IN YOUR DOOMSDAY
BUNKER AND BE THE WEIRDEST
PERVERT IN THE APOCALYPSE.